[Music]
me and my stepdad were extremely close
once I hit puberty things started to get
weird he hid video cameras and he tried
to get pictures of me and stuff as I'm
getting into the shower should I move
past my trauma to make my family more
[Music]
comfortable what's going on this is John
with the Dr John deloney show welcome
back for another adventure talking about
your marriage your emotional health your
mental health your kids whatever you got
going on in your life shows real people
going through real challenges in real
time and for the past two decades I've
been walking alongside people when the
wheels have absolutely fallen off
everything and they're trying to figure
out what to do next if you want to be on
this show give me a buzz at
84469 33291 or go to John dooney.com
[Music]
askas I hope you are into the new year
well this show comes out January 5th one
day before my birthday I'm just telling
you guys that I want fancy stuff this
year Kelly fancy
things last year you gave me a high five
and kind of an awkward hug and I still
kind of been counseling over it and I
can't shower it off so this year fancy
Things Fancy things all the things over
the past year that you have said about
me and to me and by the way I just
listened to the episode recently where I
wasn't here so yeah it's not looking
real good just so you know here we go I
I listen listen lady listen fancy things
everybody in the booth fancy fancy but I
hope you are five days into the new year
and you have not already blown all of
your um resolutions
so if you have I hope you're having a
donut all right let's go out to Toronto
Canada and talk to Laura the LA what's
up
um not much just the usual is it C you
you sound thrilled to be alive is it
freezing in
Canada it actually just snowed so for
those of us in
Tennessee what is that oh is that when
white powdery substances fall from the
sky yeah it hasn't toppled on the ground
yet fully but when I said white powdery
substance Kelly got all excited back
there in the booth so hey you did you
did all right so what's up Laura how can
I
help so I'm just going to lead with what
I sent in because otherwise my brain is
all over the place and I don't even know
where to start perfect go for it so the
question is how do I learn to enjoy the
company of
others and so the context is oh that was
the question just hold on that was the
question just by
itself yep that was the question okay
yeah unpack that for me that's that's a
that's a dense
question okay so I'm a high functioning
autistic adult with ADHD okay and I
basically feel like I haven't figured
out how to human yet
okay uh had a miserable upbringing yes
fell into the radar and basically only
got my diagnosis recently
o and essentially socializing feels
painful
okay so I don't know how to do small
talk leave a positive impression or
contribute positively to a conversation
and
relationships I can't figure out what I
bring to the table and how to connect
with
people I'm basically fighting years of
mistrust of people in
general and a brain that essentially
ruminates on almost every interaction I
have so I guess the full followup
is I guess how do I as an
adult learn to enjoy social interaction
when I'm so late in the game and
basically when my own brain is
sabotaging my
efforts um man there's a lot there walk
me back what tell me you said childhood
was was pretty hellacious tell me about
it I mean the summary is my dad was a
hoarder okay if he got a diagnosis for
bipolar I'd be surprised that he got the
diagnosis not the bipolar
part he admitted he was an alcoholic and
claimed my mom was also an alcoholic
okay basically as a result of
him and what led to your autism
diagnosis what sent you to go get a
diagnosis or did you do that on your
own I got that on my own recently I mean
did you Google it and figure fig out for
yourself or did you sit down with the
psychologist or and do some a battery of
tests it was basically I had to become
an expert on my own because I was sort
of flagged when I was a kid as having
something but they didn't know what it
was and they sort of just gave me like
slapped on a learning disability label
just for the sake of having some sort of
label through schooling okay but it was
never actually properly vetted okay and
so within the last two years I basically
did that myself and had to essentially
sort of figure out okay I think I have
this and this let me go and get tested
because the tests cost money and then
was basically gambling to figure it out
and turns out so far they've agreed with
me okay so you have you have gone to get
test yeah okay for both autism and ADHD
I mean if you ask there might be a
little bit of OCD in there but that's
just my personal opinion and that is
untested
okay um adult ADH I mean adult autism
and ADHD often get overlapping
Diagnostics that doesn't surprise me
that doesn't mean you've got two things
wrong with you okay I don't want you to
think I don't want you to think in those
terms like you just went and took your
car in because it was making a noise and
they said well it's the alternator and
the carburetor I don't want you to think
of your mind like that
okay um if it's a true Spectrum Disorder
that's that's going to be a different
conversation so I want to leave that to
an ABA Specialist or to somebody who
works specifically with adult autism
because there's going to be some gaps
there um I'd have to talk to you a long
time um in in like have an inperson
conversation with you but I'll give you
some broader context that might apply
and might also be a challenge to you so
I might not be able to solve all this
issue for you but I at least want to
give you some different perspectives or
some different ways to think about
yourself okay
m is that
cool yeah okay so when you say painful
unpack that for me be pretty
specific like interactions with other
people are painful what's where's the
pain where does the where do you
experience the pain and where does that
pain stem
from I mean I would say it starts with
literal physical discomfort okay
where
proba Sorry probably everywhere like
even in just having this phone call it's
like no no no where where in your body
where in your body does your chest get
tight does you get that warm feeling in
your stomach do you feel like you have
to go to the bathroom like where does
that sit you get
headaches it's almost like I just
immediately want to be out of the
situation but it's kind of interesting
now because I'm sort of on ADHD meds
which is new for me and it's sort of
like it's showing me all all this
anxiety that I didn't realize I had
before okay it's almost like that alarm
Bell was sort of just unplugged and now
it's sort of been plugged back in so
like right now it's like heart okay your
heart's just beating a thousand miles an
hour Fair yeah okay here's why that's
important you used a word that I love
and so I want to I want to just flip
this on its head and I want you to think
of your life in particularly your body
in this way you grew up in the home of
somebody who struggled mightily with
alcohol maybe two people are they still
married yep okay um if you grow up in
the home of someone who struggles with
alcohol it's particularly damaging
because that person is absent yet they
are right in front of you and as a kid
it's like grabbing for a ghost it's like
trying to hug somebody that looks like
they're there but they're not really
there it's in incredibly traumatic and
disorienting to a
child okay or think of it this way it's
like trying to plug something in in the
dark and you are plug you just hitting
the wall all around the plug and you
can't seem to plug it in and everyone's
yelling at you to turn the lights on
that's what it feels like right so your
body develops some really profound um
alarm systems when it comes to other
people because the two people on planet
Earth that were supposed to be as
connected as possible to
you were there yet they were gone and
you put on top of that a hoarder
somebody who you had to navigate that a
home that wasn't safe for other people
to visit to come into your parents
probably didn't go out a lot is that
fair there wasn't a lot of social
interaction NOP okay so I want you to
think through some of those things and
then I want you to come fast forward all
the way to right now how old are you
right now
31 okay I want you to consider that your
body is working
perfectly imagine you were dropped in a
bob sled in an olympic competition and
told we're going to shove you off the
edge of this bob sled and you're going
to go down the
track and we need you to
win your body would a freak out because
I've never been in a bob sled well
you're in Canada you maybe you have I
grew up in Texas I've never even seen a
bob sled in real life okay
so they put you in a bob sled shove you
off the side of course you're going to
wreck it's going to be
chaotic that that doesn't mean that you
did something wrong that means you were
set off on a roller coaster that you did
not choose and your body's trying to
keep you safe other people have been
unsafe your whole life and I bet you got
picked on like bloody hell in in grade
school didn't
you see that's maybe another part of
where the problem comes in okay
I mean I was the youngest in my family
and it's kind of like
probably lowest on the totem pole so I
sort of developed this nobody in life
has my back so I will okay mentality
yeah so like I wasn't a bully myself but
sort of good luck bullying me was a
mentality you were just a cornered a
cornered animal your whole
childhood
yes that's help out okay have you
experienced abuse of any
kind like if there was a punch thrown
and didn't hit and make contact does
that
count yes if you get hit or if an adult
tries to hurt you yes do you ever
experienced any sexual
abuse not that I would consider
that would other people consider
consider
it debatable okay but only one incident
okay one is
enough one is
enough here's the picture I'm trying to
paint for
you people have never been safe for
you so you're 31 years old and you're
beating yourself
up because your brain's trying to keep
you safe and not engage in small talk
not be around other people cuzz people
who are supposed to keep you safe hurt
you or didn't show up for you or made
you scapegoat on
things and you learn to fight to defend
yourself growing up your whole
life and then you put a potential abuse
on there and that's a different
conversation but you're talking about a
a three decades of your body trying to
protect you from other
people the the the the demon here is
that other people are like oxygen you
have to have them in your life to be
whole and yet your body has rightfully
identified them as the
problem and so if if you
are the work you have to do and it's not
going to be solved on this short phone
call the work you have to do is to teach
your body over
time that those people were not safe and
by the way if you're still in
relationship with those people I want to
challenge you to end
that end
it because every time you walk back in
that home every time you walk back in
those holiday sessions every time you
reencounter those people um who still
have agency over your
life that alarm system's going to go
off those people systematically hurt you
and took your childhood from you
on the other
side you're going to have to head into
the alarm system when it comes to being
around other people the language you
used and again I'm not going to diagnose
you with anything at all but the
language you used is language I've heard
walking with people who um adults with
um some sort of spectrum
disorder an interaction is very
transaction
and that's the way you described it I
don't bring any value I'm not doing this
the right way I need to be fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank I want you to lose the idea the
best you can of relationship being a
transaction I bring this and they bring
that so that we get
this okay A relationship is not a math
problem instead if you don't like small
talk don't engage in Small
Talk stand there like your presence is a
gift to a
conversation you learning how to do
something that very few people on Earth
know how to do well and that's listen
actually listen to somebody saying
nothing is an extraordinary
gift you can Al often enter into a
conversation say nothing or very very
little and have contributed more to the
people in that conversation than anybody
just flapping their gum
an Incredible Gift
and you deserve and desperately need
other people to listen to
you do you have somebody that you trust
a friend a neighbor somebody that um you
know well that you work with possibly a
romantic partner that that knows you
that you can be honest
with I do but I guess I sort of feel
like it's increasingly like I'm dropping
the ball somewhere because I'm sort of
feeling less un less like I can talk to
people why do you feel that way are they
giving you that signal are they telling
you that or is that a story you're
beginning to tell
yourself just based on things they've
said and ways they've
acted okay and just little things I mean
like the closest friends I would say
moved away so they're not even
physically able to meet me anymore I
sort of lost them as an
option like I have somebody I can talk
to but they're sort of more increasingly
being like saying things like I'm sort
of trying to play a victim
okay do they know your
story they do
okay somebody hears your story and says
that you're trying to be a victim
um I'd probably that that would be them
opting out of my life for a season if
not
forever you've had a pretty gnarly go of
it and I'm 100% convinced you've only
told me 10% 20%
Fair yeah pretty much yeah pretty much I
know you have a very consistent evasive
Cadence that I've heard too too often in
my in my time sitting with
people um
here's here's a way I want you to
reframe it okay and again I want you to
continue seeking care from a counselor
if you don't have one other than the
person you had to pay to go get
psychometric testing I know it's
expensive stay on the line and we're
going to hook you up with better help
for three months at least for free and
at least they can direct you okay um
give you a a ballpark at least look over
your diagnostic stuff and then give you
begin to give you a treatment plan of
some
sort when people are struggle with small
talk often is the case they struggle
with small talk because the conversation
is about them how they feel how they're
not doing how they're worried about how
they're standing how what what their
arms are doing what their hands are
doing are they saying dumb things or
silly things
or I I want your you to
practice not caring how you stand if
somebody doesn't want to be around you
cuz you stand weird God bless get them
out of your
life my friends make fun of how I use my
hands like I talk too much with my hands
and I do kind of weird things with them
when I talk I didn't even notice it
until my friends are making fun of me
one time this is decades ago and they
all love me they don't not hang out with
me because of that and I've learned I
don't care that's is how I use my hands
when I talk I'm not going to spend
effort I got too many other things in my
life I'm trying to work on so instead of
thinking of a conversation as a
performance or as a transaction I want
you to think of a coners ation as Mutual
presence one person with
another sometimes that presence can be
filled up with conversation other times
you may have to practice saying hey tell
me what's going on in your life and you
intentionally not talking about you for
a for a whole conversation just
listening just
listening not comparing not going oh
yeah what happened to me none of that
just listen just listen and when you
feel your heart rate start to beat
faster like you described on this call
or your stomach gets that feeling in it
or I want you to head into that why is
my body trying to protect me oh yeah cuz
other people have never been safe but I
think you are to whoever you're talking
with by the way people move away and
it's not your fault they didn't move
because of you they moved because life
because of a job or because they got
married or whatever they moved
away but I want you to practice being in
the presence of other people practice
feeling that discomfort and staying
there and practice
considering a conversation not as you
put $5 in I'll put $5 in and that way
we'll get $10 no no no
no not engaging in small talk how's the
weather W it's cold out here M I'm not
gonna do that how are you tell me what's
going on in your life and then just
practice
listening these are things that you will
do with a counselor you'll practice the
back and forth you'll practice The
Awkward s the awkward interactions
you'll practice nodding engaging in
small talk but saying things like hey
what lights you up these days you have a
project at work you're working
on what's the scariest thing that
happened this last
year sometimes I ask those questions and
people think I'm awkward other times
people are so grateful that's fine I am
kind of awkward that's
okay there's a lot in your story Laura I
want you to continue SE sitting with a
professional counselor professional
psychologist and
when you feel that discomfort
relationally your body's working pretty
good cuz it's been rough growing
up now the question is are you going to
head into that discomfort and find ways
to teach your body I wasn't okay then I
wasn't safe then I'm all right now
thanks for the call Laura we'll be right
back hey guys it's deloney listen as the
holidays get closer and things get more
chaotic and finances get tighter and
family members get louder and louder
opinions about
everything you can find peace with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world and even if you're not
Christian I promise you'll find Value in
stopping slowing down and praying to a
higher power listening to the prayers
spoken by other people Hall has
thousands of Christmas and Advent
prayers and meditations plus incredible
peaceful holiday music to help you
de-stress some of the music I even
listen to while I'm lifting in my garage
you can join in Hallow's pre 25
challenge with daily devotions based on
the writings of CS Lewis meditate with
scripture read by Jonathan roomy from
the TV show chosen or wind down to a
Christmas Bible story so find your sense
of calm and peace and get hallow free
for three months at hall.com
dealone that's three months free at
hall.com
delone
heyo we're back let's go to Charleston
and talk
to is there a song called Ellen no I've
never heard of a song with the main
character Ellen you should get on that
Benin all right what's up Ellen oh I
guess I got to push the button and
welcome you back hey what's up Ellen hi
Dr deloney hey uh Kelly's rolling her
eyes she's like wow how long we've done
this show three years and you don't have
to work this computer good to talk to
you Ellen what's up um well so my
husband and I have found ourselves in
sort of a pickles um so love pickles all
right uh long story short a couple of
years ago well
2021 we decided to sell our house and at
the time we had a one-year-old we were
taking care of my husband's grandmother
who was 90 and we were working full-time
jobs in the healthc care field around
covid um full background can I say
something mean your life sucked in 21
good gosh yeah
so and on top of that my husband he um
does have little OCD anxiety working in
the healthc care field with germs just
sort of sent that an
overdrive um so with especially a
newborn at the time we uh pretty much
just sort of shut down our lives um so
during that time we sort of just became
exiled we're just working jobs taking
care of our baby and um taking care of
his grandmother so anyways we decided to
sell our house and at that time his
parents wanted to downsize so he said we
would buy their home from them they
would live with us for about a year till
they found someplace to live and then
they would go their separate way and we
would no have ours I can already tell
are they still there yes oh God
so oh no so you bought their house yes
and they were going to leave quote
unquote later yes oh
Ellen Oh Ellen
hey man I don't smoke I just don't but I
want to have a cigarette right
now like right now so hey have you got
to see ringside seat where your
husband's ADHD and OCD emerged
from um well
so you're so kind and loving all right
go ahead go ahead yeah anyway so yep so
that's s where we found ourselves so now
we're in the situation that my husband
has just sort of gone to the end of his
line that he's like okay I can't live
with my parents anymore um so the
situation we're in right now is we can
buy another home and keep the current
home and his parents would like rent
from us in essence or we could sell the
home and buy a larger home so the home
we could afford right now would would be
fine but in a couple years we would want
to upgrade to another home so Ellen
Ellen Ellen Ellen y'all are GNA spend
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars to avoid a
conversation yeah don't do that don't do
that and by the way this is not your
conversation to have this is your
husband needs to be a
grownup and within the next week set up
a meeting with your mom with his mom and
dad to arrange an exit strategy for them
an exit strategy is yall have 90 days
yeah this is not your problem to solve I
hate that and and normally you you if
you've ever listened to the show I
always tell y'all are in this thing
together and this say y this is your
husband's conversation to have with his
parents this is a matter of Integrity m
they need to leave your
house within 90
days you will never be able to
sleep yeah not
yourself and both literally and
metaphorically with your
husband if he spends
$500,000 running away from a hard
conversation with his mommy and his
daddy m
I don't know how you could possibly
respect him if he does
that and I think the problem like so I
come from a family that like I don't
know if you have a problem you just sort
of speak your mind it might piss them
off for a second or two but we in
essence respect each other you know why
because you're an
adult you came from a grow up family way
to go
alen yeah Hey listen listen there is no
um I only because I've I've sat with
medical professionals and gotten the
same Diagnostics your husband has
there's not an excuse I don't care yeah
I know like in that family we just don't
have you do
now because you're in my home with my
child with my family it's
time
yeah and I guess we we have had to have
or tried to have those conversations
with his mom especially um his dad it's
it's not really his stepdad cuz when his
mom remarried my husband is already an
adult but we'll say it's stepdad you
know they he calls him dad um but they
don't have that
relationship that that that actually
makes it easier okay this is a
transaction so I feel like every like
said we've said hey we just want to know
what are your guys' game plans nope you
know what their game plan is no why
would they leave they have everything
they live in y'all's house y'all pay the
bills just make it a business
transaction this is the deal you have 90
days and you're you got to find
something it's it's a little more
delicate but it would be your husband
not you because you as some complexity
to it okay I wish that wasn't the case
but you do your husband takes his mom
and his step dadish sort of dad or guy
that remarried when he was an adult but
he calls Dad yeah that
honestly not this is a tangent that
tells me what I need to know about your
husband he's so uncomfortable with any
sort of relational discomfort
period he's willing to call a guy that
he's didn't meet until he was out of the
house who married his mom dad yeah
that's all I need to you know what I'm
saying that's not that's
odd like that's out of a will farell
movie like brothers got a hug right that
I mean it's
like but here we are that's what I need
to know about your husband okay he needs
to take both of those adults out and say
y'all have been with us for two years we
bought your house from you with a plan
that y'all were going to stay with us
for a while and you're going to find
your place it's it's time for me and my
family to establish our own roots in our
own
home and that is where he'll normally
goes so what are y'all thinking what are
your plans are they're not thinking
anything other than they've got it made
in the shade yeah so Mom by March 1
we're going to have to ask you to move
out and find your own place me and my
family need our own
home
period end the
story
oh you're just throwing us out no no no
if that's how you want to hear it you're
welcome to do that you're an adult but
no we agreed when we bought your house
you're going to stay with us for a
little while it's been two
years and then as I learned after many
years working with attorneys there is
power in the pause I'm not going to seek
to fill that angsty silence or
discomfort
I'm going to State my boundaries very
clearly and with love and dignity and
respect youall have to leave my house
now and I can tell by your silence
there's no way this conversation is
happening is
there um I think my husband is to the
point that he is desperate for anything
okay I know he knows it's difficult but
I think he's willing to do what's going
to be best long term okay
you are not wimping out and you are not
making him quote unquote carry the
burden by himself by you not going to
this meeting it's appropriate for you to
not be there uhhuh
okay I think you have significant input
on the front end of the conversation now
do youall get free babysitting and stuff
like
that his mother is our child care okay
y'all are gonna have to deal with that
yeah because she might say screw you
guys then I'm going
home or he might say I need y'all to
move out we need our own place Mom I
would still like to hire you to be our
child care person
yeah have all have him map all that out
y'all two map all that out together but
remember she's an adult and she gets to
do whatever she wants she get it's her
life and if she wants to throw a temper
tantrum and walk away from her grandkids
and her son and his his great wife that
will suck but she gets to do
that if she recognizes yeah we need to
leave this you're
right then and she wants to stay and it
works out great she wants to stay
childcare provider
awesome but here's what's happening very
quickly and it's not fair to Mom or to
new
dad y'all are growing to resent them
yeah when they call when they walk in
when the car pulls
up you're growing to really be disgusted
by
them and I don't think that's their
fault should they have left by now yes
they're
not and so you can't in one hand put out
your hand to have somebody shake it and
then be grossed out or disgusted or
angry when they shake it
back it's your job to not extend your
hand
anymore and so I'd much rather preserve
the relationship with my mom and my new
dad even if it's when it's
uncomfortable instead of being angry or
resentful every time they call or show
up to the place quite frankly I invited
them to
live it makes
sense I know it's not easy
though can I high five you from
Nashville
I know this this just sucks for
you and I I'm tell I'll just reiterate
this again if you all go spend hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of dollars to
avoid this this season you're going to
lose a lot of respect for your husband
and you're going to feel pretty isolated
and on your
own well that was my argument I felt
like we were just running and not
solving any issue you are a wise wise
woman so I mean I but I mean from his
perspective he's like I just need some
time to think and he would but I don't
think that's really going to solve it
there's nothing to think about how long
has it been two years yeah two
years
Tada
Tada two years there's nothing else to
think about that's just a that's a
that's an avoidance strategy that's
punting on second down there's no reason
to do
it there's no reason to do it
just delaying the
inevitable this is his conversation to
have with his mother and his
dad and you and your husband come up
with the terms of this thing here's how
much you got 90 days you got six months
I don't care what the date is but it has
to be a firm date that yall communicate
to
them possibly in writing I don't know if
they're renting the house from you but
y'all can decide that but there needs to
be it needs to be unambiguous everybody
needs to be clear as we say around here
where I work clear is
kind and expect some frustration some
sad some what of course they've they've
grown accustomed to living in your life
and y'all have become their
entertainment y'all have become their
insta family y'all are their source
of like shelter probably food and it's
time for you and your husband to grow up
on your own and get your own place and
if your husband struggling with OCD and
ADHD it's his job to go get the help he
needs I know because I've been there
that's his
job what a mess do me a favor call me
after this conversation because I'm
interested to know how it goes and we'll
put you back on the air or if he wants
to call and practice the call or
whatever I'm happy to talk to him too
but I'm interested to hear how this goes
and for everybody listening out
there it always sounds like a good idea
y'all just move in quote unquote for a
while whether you're adult with adult
kids or vice
versa you're ad kids and you're like oh
yall just Mom and Dad y'all just move in
for a while Mom just move in for a while
you can live in the basement for a
while always have a date on there always
you can revisit the date but always have
some clarity otherwise it gets into this
swampy mess and everybody comes out
smelling like swamp
gas and unless you're Kelly GH that's
gross she's kind of been to it it's just
a thing we'll be right
back if you've listen to my show any
amount of time you've definitely heard
me talk about Thorne Thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming they the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorn is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our Delon show
listeners go to thorne.com
delone choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com
thelet
youone check it
out all right we're back let's go down
to the 512 in Austin Texas and talk to
Heather what's up
Heather hello hey what's up um so my
question question is should I move past
my trauma to make my family more
comfortable I don't even know what your
trauma is in the answer is back story
yeah I don't know if you know what it is
but your the answer to your question is
no no I don't even know what happened I
don't even care what happened yeah but
the answer is no now tell me what
happened okay so um my mom married my
stepdad when I was in like fifth grade I
guess and we were extremely close me and
my step dad and then um once I hit
puberty things started to get weird um
you know he would make comments about
different things and it slowly kept
escalating to the point where he would
text me strange things um you're being
very vague talk talk talk me through it
yeah so he he texted me when I was 15 I
you know as a 15-year-old girl I wanted
to drive to school the next day I didn't
even have a license so I went in my room
throwing a tantrum as teenage girls too
and he texted me and said if you send me
a video I will let you drive to school
and I immediately was like what are you
talking about and he said never mind
delete this text message don't tell
anyone well I you know went to my school
counselor the next day good for you and
um they called my mom in and apparent I
don't remember any of that like my brain
is blocked it out um but my sisters told
me
that they had to sit down with him my
stepdad and he said he was crying you
know and he said he would get counseling
all these different things and he never
did um and then it just you know he
started he hid video cameras and he
tried to get pictures of me from under
the doors and stuff as I'm getting into
the shower and different
things um and so for the last I would
say five years I've had zero contact
with him um I wrote him a long letter
and let him know you know I know you did
all of these things the whole family
knows you've done all these things and
you're no longer welcome at family
events and so everybody's kind of stuck
with that everyone was fine with it hold
on Heather Heather Heather why isn't he
in
jail I never my mom's still married to
him so it's very complicated situation
yeah well hold
on your feelings and your you're driving
what happens next that's complicated in
heart okay and I'll honor that to the to
the end of
time it is not complicated because your
mom chose a child molester and a sex
offender over her
children that is not why it's
complicated
yeah
okay yeah you as I you know as well as I
do that going through like just that
conversation that you don't aren't even
able to remember would tell both of us
that going to court and going through
all the drama and getting put on this
stand all that stuff would be really
really
tough and if you choose to not go
through that that's your choice to make
as the person who experienced
this but your mom made her
choice yeah and it disgusts me to know I
cannot even wrap my head around it you
know why cuz I got a seven-year-old
little
girl and I'll burn the world down for
her
yeah yeah and listen listen you deserved
that and I'm sorry that
happened yeah my mom has her own set of
issues like she's an alcoholic and um
bipolar and all sorts of things Heather
hether I know that's not an excuse don't
care don't care I don't care you
deserved a mom that would fight for you
till the end of time you don't have that
yeah you deserved a dad that would have
stuck around and you deserved a stepdad
that would honor you like his
own my so my biological father is in the
picture he was a truck driver so I think
that's why I clung so close to my
stepdad because it was the first time I
had like a father figure consistently
there every day you
know um and I didn't my real dad had no
idea any of this was going on until I
was 23 I told
him that he had no
clue
geez so um but so fast forward to July
of this year my grandmother passed away
and my mom asked if my stepdad could
come to the funeral to support
her um and I was you know already
distraught from losing my grandmother so
I told her I don't care I just don't
want him to talk to me I don't want him
sitting next to me I but I don't care if
he's there and that went fine
surprisingly um it didn't bother me I
don't know if I was just in shock or
what um so I guess the rest of the
family took that as like I'm over it and
now he can be invited to Thanksgiving
and weddings and Christmas and different
things like that um and and uh honestly
feel like I kind of fell for it because
I was having a conversation with my
husband and we have two kill two kids
ourselves and I was like telling him I
didn't care if he was there and he's
arguing you know well our kids aren't
going to be around him and I almost felt
like I was defending my stepdad because
my family wants him back at these family
events and I just don't know how to
handle that can I pretend you were my
can I pretend you were like my best
friend yeah or my sister actually be
different if it was you were my
sister I would tell you to never go
around my family ever again
ever and if you've ever listened to this
show for any length of time you know
I've never said those words until just
now
yeah but not a single one of your family
members that you've described on your
side of your family deserves to be in
the same universe as
you
yeah of course that guy's on his best
behavior you know why he should be in
jail yeah and that's you know what my
sister was saying she's like um you know
it's not like he's ever going to be
alone with the kids like everyone's
going to be watching him like a HW it
doesn't ma it doesn't matter yeah yeah
matter it as well okay it doesn't
matter I'm you're not the crazy one Hey
listen the fact that you said in this
call um that somehow you messed
something I must have been you know
grieving
yes you didn't do anything
wrong
yeah yeah you didn't do anything
and you can do a lot right moving
forward I don't know that i' I'm not
hearing in your story that you've ever
properly grieved
the fact that your mother sided
with a
um
disgusting disgusting human being over
her
daughter yeah I hav't I've always been a
mommy's girl and I've always been the
person that stands up for her bad
actions and so trauma you've probably
heard this the fight or flight you've
heard that before yeah have you heard
freeze uh no okay there's fight flight
or freeze but there's a fourth one that
is not talked about very
often it's called Fawn f a w
n it's when people hurt us so
bad that we keep ourselves safe by
nuzzling up really really close to the
person who keeps hurting
us that makes a lot of sense maybe
they'll stop I can't defeat them or I
won't punch them I can't get out of them
cuz out of this relationship because it
would be too
painful but I'm going to take action my
body hasn't shut me down I'm just
Frozen yeah I'm G to get as close as
humanly possible and make sure
everything's perfect so they I won't
become a target of their
evil
yeah you got it's it's time to it's time
to be absolutely done with them so
grossed out and disgusted for you
Heather I'm so
sorry yeah I
thanks I don't I just don't know how to
here's how here's how how I tell my
family you know that in all honesty
Heather they
don't gosh I'm I'm going against
everything I almost say always they
don't get an
explanation yeah here's what I would how
I would say it and I'd be very clear I
would write a letter dear Mom and if
sister's involved too whoever saying
like well you know it's going to be okay
because we're
gonna yeah I was one of my sister told
me that he's not a sex offender because
he never physically touched
me oh
man
yeah your sister's
wrong yeah and so here's what the letter
would say dear fill in the blank and I
would name them
all
for multiple years this man took
advantage of me sexually in my own
home I reported it and the only adults
that stood by me were school
officials and when it continued to
happen my body shut
down because nobody was coming to
help I've been very clear over the years
that this man is not welcome in my life
at family functions family
events I mistakenly allowed him to
attend a funeral in support of my mom
and suddenly that has become permission
it was seen as permission for him to
show up
everywhere as such I will no longer be
attending any and all family functions
period I wish yall the best
Heather yeah and listen that's
it if you are my best friend I would
tell you to block them and delete them
from your
phone yeah they have walked away from
you in a really grotesque
way yeah and then I want you to write a
letter to 13-year-old
Heather and tell her I'm so sorry that
no adult came to help
you and let 13-year-old Heather know
that that crap stops with you because
you're you're going to defend your
daughters you're going to believe your
daughters and somebody will break your
daughter's heart somebody will hurt your
daughters that's the nature of the
game but you will never turn your back
on them like it happened to
you yeah
fair fair very
fair have you talked to somebody over
the years about
this I have not it's
time
yes it's time
can I tell you why how old are your
daughters uh my daughter is eight and I
also have a son who's four
okay have you started getting super
hypervigilant very I mean my husband I
watch him like a Haw and he's an angel
he would never do anything have you ever
heard me talk about GPS pins
before I don't believe so okay you ever
sent somebody a location like where are
you and you just send them a quick GPS
pin P yeah okay your body does that
too and your body put a GPS pin in men
left alone with little
girls because you were taken advantage
of of of by one for a long
time yeah in a number of different ways
and a number of different
places
M your brain knows that when a man is
around nowhere is safe not even the
shower not even the bathroom not even
your
bedroom not even your
phone yeah and so it's
indiscriminate every time you see a
grown man with a little girl your body
sounds the alarm
system yeah and that's what that
hypervigilance
is I'm going to tell you something
really hard okay okay most people stop
the conversation here because are so
terrified of this thing called victim
shaming okay MH I'm not blaming you for
one thing that happened what happened to
you was evil and wrong and hellacious
and I hate the fact that no adults came
to rescue you because that was their job
yeah
and your husband doesn't deserve to be
treated like a predator in his own home
Fair very fair yes that means it's your
work to
do and we want our daughters mine and
yours we want them to be aware and
understanding but we don't want them to
live in Terror like you've had to live
the last 20 something years of your life
Fair very fair it's time for you to go
talk to somebody this is your work to do
okay yeah okay will you commit to that I
will you promise yes you deserve to
Exhale for the first time in 25
years yeah you deserve to sleep all
night for the first time in 25 years and
you don't sleep I know no you don't yeah
I don't sleep you know why cuz your body
would be failing you if it let you sleep
because there's a man in the house with
a young
girl yeah
right and it's time for you to let that
13-year old girl go be a knuckleheaded
13-year-old girl Let Her Go be 15 and
throw temper tantrums in a
room right right
yeah yeah for sure and let's let your
husband have deep
really close connected relationship with
his young
daughter they both desperately need
that yeah
right yes
okay what you're doing you are changing
your family tree and you're cutting ties
with
evil yeah and you know as well as I do
they're going to guilt trip you they're
going to drag you back into the fold so
I would cut all ties I would delete them
out of my phone they have cashed out
they chose a sexual PR creditor over
their daughter or their
sister and if I were you I would spend
weeks weeping over that like
devastated and then we're going to
figure out what comes next because
that's the that's the world that's the
cards you were dealt
unfortunately
yeah Fair very fair thank you so much
for all of your advice no thank you for
being honest and your question as we
started this thing do I need to cash
out I'm having to take a deep breath
hold
on I
just no you never have to swallow your
trauma so that other members of your
family can go on with their little
fantasy
land
if an adult chooses to stay with
somebody who hits
you who leaves you who sexually abuses
you and that person's your mom or that
person's your husband or your that
person's your dad they're
out they have looked at you and said I
don't want to be in relationship with
you in a real
world I'm choosing evil over
you and they're going to try to make it
your fault walk
away
I'm telling youall as a community we got
to start taking care of our
kids because the ROI on not taking care
of them and this culture of abuse and
this culture of don't tell anybody and
this culture
of the insane amount of sexual abuse
that goes on with adults and kids that
goes unreported that goes unprosecuted
that goes on oh he didn't mean it he's
actually a good is staggering and you
know how I know cuz I've sat with these
women for
decades and until the adults in the
world start coming to the rescue of
these
kids and not protecting
EV we will have hell to pay and we'll
deserve every single bit of
it we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right we're back I went for a walk
for a minute cuz I needed to go for a
walk after that last call and so here's
what we do normally or in the past um
when I end with a call like that it's
just hard
and that rattles me a little bit or a
lot um I usually just end the show and
I've had some people ride in and say
hey that's actually when like the song
of the day or am I the like some funny
thing at the end or silly thing at the
end um helps bring us all back
up and so instead of just walking away
and letting that hang uh like that I
we're going to do a quick am I the
problem is it
me and we'll just take a left turn here
yep and try to put some light back in a
pretty dark moment exactly sound good y
if you're asking am I the problem
because that's the shirt you chose to
wear no you look
nice go
ahead you look
nice but just go ahead you you you I'm
GNA buy you a book on how to give
compliments because you really suck at
it just so you
know go for it all right this is from
Joe in Fort Smith
Arkansas hey all I'm 54 I work in a
warehouse environment with five other
adult males I had a situation with a
coworker in which he told me to calm
down I felt disrespected and made the
choice to walk away but to cease
communication with this
individual about 6 weeks of not speaking
to him he confronted me about it in
front of other
employees I explained my feelings of
disrespect and my choice to ignore him
his response was sorry you feel that way
but I'm used to dealing with adults for
a second time I felt blatantly
disrespected and this time I went
nuclear I stormed into the office and
informed my supervisor that intervention
was immediately required the
intervention ended up being a lectur to
both of us about how y'all need to
respect one another and get along
because this is a warehouse crew and you
have work to do 8 weeks later I haven't
spoken another word to that person and I
never will and I also have frustrations
toward my supervisor am I a child and am
I the
problem
Kelly I'm rarely speechless and I am
speechless it's a great day
I I see what you did there
um I mean based on that
email that a cooworker said and I quote
you need to calm
down yes six weeks of Silence feels a
bit like a lot
and then when that person was finally
was like hey why are you ignoring
me and then you explained it and they
were like yeah I just thought I was
working with a
grown-up I mean that's probably what I
would
say I I I don't think this person would
last very long on this team is what I'm
saying
yeah I I mean there's there has to be
more to
this
I there has to be telling someone to
calm down by the way no one in the
history of the world has ever calmed
down when being told to calm down
correct but we've all said it you're
like dude calm down we've all you know
how many times you've told me that this
week probably a million at least yeah
and John calm down but it's not
something to get like or even you know
what hey the way you said that in front
of all of our teammates really hurt my
feelings or made me feel disrespected or
what ever but be an adult dude yeah I I
would say this the silent treatment is
as childish as it gets an adult if even
let's say the calm down was completely
uncalled for and worth fighting over or
worth like I'm bringing the pain um
taking your ball and going home is a
childish response fine I'm not going to
talk to you anymore um so if you want to
be an adult and pull them aside
privately and say hey when you told to
calm down in front of all the people
that embarrass me please don't do that
again and they can go oh sorry you're an
adult and be like I am an adult don't
talk to me like that that's belittling
that would be an adult way to handle an
uncomfortable
situation um just choosing eight months
later I will never talk to you again
yeah that just sounds like it's off
Dawson's Creek or
something so yeah well when they work in
a warehouse so they're gonna have to
interact with each other right yeah how
does that work I don't yeah and with a
small T he said five people so out of
the five people you're mad at one person
and the
supervisor odds aren't looking good for
you getting a Christmas card from
anybody yeah I sorry man I think the
problem's you and let me say this um I
like to when I feel trapped and I bring
it to somebody else and they're like
yeah what's the matter with you and then
I get super pissed at them and I bring
it to somebody else and they're like
yeah dude what's the matter with you at
some point you do one of two things you
finally go to the mirror and go all
right maybe it's
me or you just don't ever talk to him
ever ever
again that's what I think Andrew hasn't
talked to any of us like in seven months
Kelly I don't I don't talk much in
general so it's nothing personal it's
true keeps us all safe so yeah I mean
you think he's a problem Oh 100%
100% I'm all dancing around it trying to
be like well you know and you're like
yeah 100% even if the other guy was a
jerk like you said and called him out
have a conversation and be like hey dude
that really because I mean it might have
said it in front of a big group of
people and been super mocking about it
he could have been a jerk about it but
say something pide hey don't do that
again yeah be like please don't ever do
that again that was rude but
dude I've never speaking to him
again yeah I mean that's the definition
of childish child yeah yeah yeah yeah
stupid if you can't say something nice
nice Kelly don't say something at
all all right hey that's Today's
Show Hey listen go tip the waitress at
wherever you eat next Triple what you're
going to tip triple it's a new year
times are tough let's put some joy and
light back in the world this is a heavy
heavy show love you guys stay in school
don't do drugs
bye